in the last hour it's been announced
that Manchester City's two-year ban from
European football has been lifted this
means the Premier League club will now
be able to compete in next season's UEFA
Champions League competition well let's
get more from scratch Tom Palmiter who
is at the Etihad Stadium a match that
and joins us now tell us more about this
Tom insufficient
conclusive evidence was the nub of what
we found out this morning around the
court of arbitration decision who have
been looking at this since February when
UEFA said that munch City had committed
serious breaches of the financial Fair
Play rules well the ruling today
suggests that that isn't the case and
that the band that had been imposed on
their participation on European club
competitions for the next two seasons as
as you say been lifted they found that
they did not disguise funding as
sponsorship contributions but did
obstruct the UEFA investigation so this
will still be fined munch City ten
million euros about eight point nine
million pounds and what's that a club of
these riches something like the cost of
a decent youth player but I think the
reputational damage and reputation that
was on the line here is perhaps the
biggest thing and of course the riches
of the Champions League is well
documented and that will be open now to
Manchester see they've finished second
in the Premier League this season that
was confirmed over the last few days and
they will be able to compete now in the
Champions League and it gives them the
stability to plan and to continue to
attract the top talent to the Etihad
Stadium here and Pep Guardiola who has
one year left on his contract he said
that he would stay regardless of the
decision today but it just gives them
the ability to continue in the way that
they want to continue they'd hired a top
legal team under city to fight this they
were very aggressive in their pushing
back on the fact that they believed they
had done nothing wrong they said that it
was something of a witch-hunt it was
based on hacked emails this case but
certainly a significant victory today
probably more significant than their
fine
five no win over the weekend this is
something that gives manchester city the
stability to have the assurances that
they can give to top players thinking
about coming into Manchester or perhaps
even leaving this club that they will
have that Champions League football for
the next two seasons and they'll be able
to crack on with that as soon as they
get through this year's competition
which they are still in they'll do to
try and get past Real Madrid this year
in that shrunk down version of the
competition that will take place fairly
soon